foreign
[Applause]
Castle Cinemas I'm one of your hosts
Kevin Smith and this is the last night
the awards ceremony if you will of the
very first mod Castle Film Festival put
your hands together my friends
I I'll tell you like I told Ernie man
this has been a real delight and I don't
mean to say that in a way that I was
[ __ ] shocked and surprised but my
expectations were pretty [ __ ] minimal
and like Ernie put a [ __ ] legit event
together and I realized that when I was
doing the panels uh today at uh the
originals mod Castle over in Leonardo
right next to Quick Stop uh mere feet
from where I dreamed of being a
filmmaker and where I [ __ ] would
write in a journal like one day I can
help open a film Co-op so everyone could
get a camera and make their own movies
and [ __ ] like that I didn't have to do
that Apple did it for you and stuff so
there was another dream on the list
though that said uh in five years build
a film festival and so we're living in
that [ __ ] dream even though I'm not
the reason we're here today I've said it
many times I'm going to say it here
especially uh because it's going to tie
in to a really nice introduction
um this all begins at the smod castle uh
Podcast Theater are in Leonardo I'm
right next to Quick Stop in the blogging
stores about a year ago
Ernie refurbished that place turned it
into what it was and whatnot and after
the Pod after the pandemic we opened up
and started doing shows and I think it
was after like the second show we had a
crowd of people and a crowd for us in
those days was 50 because that's all
that room is legally allowed to hold
Ernie was like we should do a film
festival here and like you'd imagine
that I've been like [ __ ] a but
instead the guy whose entire [ __ ]
career began at a film festival was like
why and he was like because I've been
making films I've been submitting the
film festivals and it's kind of easy now
film freeway makes it easy we got a
space this is a place where people could
show their work and stuff and so it
began at that little theater 50-seater
with our video screen up top we got a
pretty big TV there and stuff so we were
like this will be a great place for it
and then we started doing events here at
the Atlantic movie house with Tony Tony
after the pandemic reopened uh what you
know used to be the Atlantic Highlands
twins cinnamon when I was a kid renamed
it the Atlantic Movie House and put it
back in business post pandemic so we
started coming here to do [ __ ] like Jay
and Stalin Bob get old do Live Events
I'd come to the place
over the last two years my friend Janet
Peterson works with the film one
Festival so I'd been here to do benefits
with them and stuff and you know this is
the theater I grew up going to when I
was a kid my father took me here to see
movies I went here all through high
school and on Friday nights it looked
like this like just [ __ ] packed you
couldn't find a [ __ ] seat and stuff
like that so being back in the theater
and and like being in the room and
working with Tony like suddenly me and
Ernie were like well if we're doing a
film festival maybe we can partner up
with the Atlantic Movie House and like
show some films at smog castle and maybe
rent a theater in the Atlantic movie
house and show some movies there so
it'll feel like a real film festival and
then we talked to Tony about doing a a
co-op man like a conjunction like let's
team up man and so that conversation
eventually led to
um Jeff Swan saying to Ernie you know
the [ __ ] theaters for sale
and we knew that in the back of our
minds years ago Mr rast when I was here
for the film one Fest Mr raster we
bought the theater from Mr rast was the
mayor of Atlantic Highlands at one point
it's a very interesting [ __ ]
gentleman and his uh his his uh daughter
was our schoolmate me and Ernie went to
school with Michelle Mishi Ras man the
smartest kid in [ __ ] class and [ __ ]
and I'm happy to report she turned out
really well she got like a [ __ ] hella
husband who I would [ __ ] and like he's
really good looking I saw him at the
reunion show I was like meesh you did
well man you might have done too well
keep an eye on this [ __ ] dude and uh
she's got beautiful kids and all that
stuff so anyway Mr rast uh owned the
theater and he had talked about like you
should buy it you make movies and I was
like why what would I do with the movie
theater
and then Jeff suggested to Ernie and
Ernie was just like you know the the
movie theater is for sale and we were in
the process of trying to buy quick stop
at that point which kind of uh got put
on hold uh because the Toppers are going
through a thing so you know I was in the
middle of something with Ashley my
partner Ashley and about quick stop and
suddenly it was on hold and we had a
bunch of funds that were going to go
into that that were just kind of sitting
here and suddenly those funds made a lot
more sense if we put it into the theater
so I asked Ash I was like I know what
Anna convenience store business but like
I didn't want to be in the movie
business you know
and she was like yeah and so suddenly it
was me and Ashley and and Jeff and Ernie
and then we pulled Tony into it as well
because Tony [ __ ] saved the theater
and kept it open and [ __ ] suddenly we
had a fellowship all came back together
and bought the theater and so suddenly
this mod Castle Film Festival which
began in one room like [ __ ] Little
House on the Prairie Style
graduated to a multiplex that we
actually [ __ ] owned the smog Castle
Film Festival took place in smodcast
Castle Cinemas man the chances of all
that playing out in that [ __ ] way and
happening the way it did infinitesimal
and yet it [ __ ] happened because
that's what dream the power of dreaming
can do it sounds corny as [ __ ] I know I
sound like Tony Robbins but I'm [ __ ]
serious I stand in front of you as a
person who stands in front of you
because of the power of [ __ ] dreams
and we're living tonight not in my dream
but in the dream of Somebody That I Used
to spend my childhood with dreaming you
know sitting beside going imagine we did
this imagine we did that we're both old
as [ __ ] but we're still getting to live
those dreams by playing in this [ __ ]
giant fun house we've called us mod
Castle Cinemas this place has come along
the exact right time in my [ __ ] life
man and it couldn't be more welcome I'm
gonna spend I figure I have to post
heart attack I got about like 20 years
left for my [ __ ] life I'm gonna spend
every [ __ ] you it's true I'm gonna
it's not a grim thought man I'm
painfully aware that life is short man
well you know if I can act accordingly
so I'm going to spend all 20 of them
[ __ ] above this place just having fun
you know the first beginning in my
career was like I want to make a movie
and then the middle of my career was
like I gotta keep making movies what the
[ __ ] and now I'm at a place in my career
I was like I'll make movies if I want
but what I really want to do is show
Black Panther and then do a q a after it
even though I had nothing to do with the
movie
yeah
excuse me
so people be like whatever happened to
him how'd he die they're like happy but
weird
um
so uh even though I [ __ ] literally
live right above the theater it's still
I'm a half an hour late go figure so
thank you uh for your patience
um tonight kids uh I gotta finish that
in that dedication because I didn't
finish it uh we're only here because of
one person man a person I love dearly
and a person who put all this [ __ ]
together and when I was sitting at the
pot at smod Castle earlier today doing
the panels
um I had a I'm used to people showing up
to things from what I assume is pity
like when I throw an event I when people
show up I'm like they feel sorry for me
that's why they come that's why they
spend the money because they feel sorry
for me and [ __ ] like that and generally
it's all about me right they're asking
me questions about my work and stuff
when we did our second panel today and
we opened it up to questions and every
one of those people in the room who I
was and what I did but they didn't give
a [ __ ] about me they wanted to talk to
the guy from decentralized pictures
because like that [ __ ] could
help me pay for a [ __ ] thing
um same with the panel that came
afterwards man we were talking Eric
Wilkinson from MVD everyone was dialed
into him never mind me and my [ __ ]
like haha show and whatnot they're like
you ain't gonna help me get my movie
[ __ ] Finance or distributed these
[ __ ] will and in the eyes of the
audience I saw myself reflected I
remember being that person who would go
to a film festival sit in the audience
listen to some quasi-professional talk
hoping to grab one more piece of
information that might make the journey
a little bit [ __ ] easier or make the
journey possible at all so today when I
was conducting the panels at smog Castle
I I realized holy [ __ ] this wasn't just
like a thing where we showed movies and
stuff like we became a legitimate Film
Festival people came here looking for
[ __ ] information and I hope they
walked away with some of that
information if not meeting people who
might have that information if not
meeting people who can help them make
their next flick if nothing else
I really wish that I was here for every
intro and and stuff sometimes I had to
split time and go over there because all
of it was so [ __ ] magical for me and
that magic was created by one [ __ ]
wizard he's as old as Gandalf
and about as wise ladies and gentlemen
uh give it up you know every if you ever
watch the Golden Globes right in the
beginning of the Golden Globes they're
like this year's Golden Glow bed or
whatever is some famous fucker's kid and
it's always somebody this is Alec
Baldwin's kid or something that's the
tradition like nepo babies Galore and
[ __ ] so in the tradition of that I would
like to introduce you to our trophy gal
tonight the lady who will be handing me
the trophies that I give off to the
winners uh please welcome Castle keeper
Ernie O'Donnell ladies and gentlemen
speech
[Music]
[Applause]
you are a [ __ ]
not many people can say go [ __ ] himself
on stage but I will say it
uh I this guy doesn't know how much I
love him uh but yes
um
he's made a lot of my dreams come true
and when we were kids like he said we
wanted to be in the movie business
together we started out
what we started with India what was it
Indiana Jones with a eight what was it
Indiana Jones and the lost ball yes
so we
we found a uh I think it was an incense
statue at some a place called Mrs wig's
Trunk in Highlands and that was our lost
ball so we create well actually Kevin
wrote a a script he played bellock
and of course which really consisted of
me just doing one line over and over
Jones
I'll give you one last chance Jones like
is there's a moment in the movie where
he's yelling up at [ __ ] Indiana Jones
but I would do that right to Ernie's
face Jones
it was it was the greatest thing ever it
was probably the spark of one of the
many things that brought us here today
it took us a long time to get here but
God am I so proud that we're here uh and
to do with anybody else would just not
be right to do my man Kevin who I call
Smitty uh for 42 years is [ __ ]
amazing so uh
I wanna
I wanna thank him for entrusting in me
and giving me the reins to make this
happen because throughout this whole
process
he's been letting all of you know and
his millions of fans on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook that if this
thing [ __ ] up it's Ernie's fault
foreign
and that's okay because I can handle
that and uh I hope we did a good job for
you guys and we were looking forward to
having you back for next year thank you
uh okay kids let's get to the meter why
we [ __ ] came here tonight man
um
awards are uh tricky things uh
especially for a guy who doesn't win
them anymore
um
you know I would love to be able to be
like oh [ __ ] Awards they mean nothing
it's all about the the pursuit of the
truth and the lie that tells the truth
and stuff and that's absolutely true but
the fact of the matter is I've never
been in it for the prizes or the awards
I didn't think I'd ever do anything
award-worthy in the beginning of my
career they thought differently and they
would give me Awards and [ __ ] and then a
couple years into my career they got
smart and they're like he don't get no
more Awards and stuff and at that point
I developed this weird Theory where I
was like you know I don't do it for the
awards [ __ ] Awards and stuff like that
so um we don't do it for the rewards but
it's always nice when there are Awards
and just because there are Awards uh
doesn't mean that somebody who doesn't
win one uh isn't worthy by any
stretching the imagination God bless you
I hope that's not [ __ ] covid man
we're just just getting out of the Dark
Ages [ __ ] um
so everyone of course who I'm not even
going to do the all the nominees or
winners and [ __ ] I'm gonna go deeper
than that anybody who made a [ __ ]
thing you're already one you're already
way
it's and that's no hype
that's no [ __ ]
doesn't matter if you walk away with the
goofy trophy or not like that you've
done something that [ __ ] 98 of the
population is never going to bother to
[ __ ] do ever you're a [ __ ]
astronaut there's only one of [ __ ]
ten thousand twenty thousand of you in
the world right now now I don't mean
people that dream about doing a thing I
mean people that [ __ ] execute and
Elevate that thing everyone can dream
that's the equal opportunity employer
right there but to take the next step
and make it a [ __ ] reality to
manifest reality from Pure Imagination
and some Willy Wonka [ __ ] right there
and that means you win instantly
that being said we took the [ __ ]
smart approach because when we were
building the festival
um Ernie was like do we bring together a
panel of judges and [ __ ] like that and I
was like what give somebody a reason to
hate me again no [ __ ] way I was like
we shouldn't be the judges the audience
should be the judge let's put it on them
and so you all voted and judged and
that's how we've got to the the prize
people who get prizes oh [ __ ] look at
them they're [ __ ] nice I didn't
realize they were behind me I'm so
blazed
um
you're gonna walk away with one of these
[ __ ] cool statues and [ __ ] like that
uh here we go kids we're gonna go
starting
with uh best actor drama in the short
film category
the nominees are
Heather Britton oh Scanlon victim number
six
Colin James O'Gorman Eugene versus
Humanity
Sean Joseph young sometime else
foreign
Phillips sugar
and Nick Walker dream of me
and the prize for best actor drama short
goes to
Heather Britton oscanland victim number
six come on up Heather
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Applause]
ing wow holy cow thank you thank you oh
my gosh
did not expect this I won't keep you
going because we're already running a
little late so I'm conscious of that but
um I I thank you gosh this is wow it's a
pig
you guys it's a heavy Golden Pig
it's not
what what oh it's a cow it's a cow
[Applause]
a cow it's a heavy golden cow and I'm
it's the most beautiful heavy golden cow
anyone's ever given me no actually
seriously thank you this is thank you
Ernie and Kevin and everybody involved
with the festival it's
feels really good to be up here at my
director Nancy couldn't be here tonight
she got sick unfortunately not coveted
but sick
um Russ was here earlier our leading man
it was the first time he got to see it
in a theater which was so nice and this
is the theater that I've been coming to
for 20 years so thank you for buying it
and keeping theater alive
so and thanks to all you thank you
um okay the next Pig goes to uh sorry
uh next up we're doing the best actor
comedy uh short category ladies and
gentlemen and our nominees are Jake
barcus for brew story
correct me if I'm wrong Christine salazi
thank you for my friends the plants
Chris gethard the f word
Godfrey for the [ __ ]
and Kelly rumin for rekindled
and the best actor comedy short trophy
the Pig goes to
Kelly Vrooman rekindled
come over here thank you
um
uh thanks so much so I am not Kelly but
Kelly is one of my best friends who
starred and rekindled and
um we make a lot of things together we
both love making movies and every time
something like this happens it gets us
closer to our next one so thank you
okay we're going to best comedy short
kids here we go the nominees were or are
Bruce story give it up for him
the f word give it up for him
Jimmy give it up for him
rekindled
and finally the [ __ ]
you all took directions so well I
stopped saying give it up for him he
just kept giving it up well done man uh
and the winner of best comedy short is
Jimmy
come on up
[Applause]
close you want to touch whatever you
need
[Applause]
space
all right well this is [ __ ] awesome
pretty sweet are sure Jimmy has a 13
inch penis in it which is pretty cool
it's probably has something to do with
it it's awesome yeah quick story we were
we were at Sundance we went to go see a
movie called sweetheart we had the
ticket we didn't get in because we were
slightly late uh and we were walking
through the parking lot saying what have
we seen a lot of this year
wieners uh so we said let's put a dick
in our next movie
well done boys
there it is kids that's the secret to
success
huge dick
uh okay we're moving on folks this is
the uh these are the nominees for the
best drama short category here we go
dream of me
the fourth
the invention
Matthew
squall
and the winner of the best drama short
uh award goes to dream of me
[Applause]
oh my God it's not an award ceremony
until somebody's not here
uh I'll accept it because this is
[ __ ] awesome this is going up in my
apartment thank you everybody I really
feel like I worked hard for this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
everyone's a winner
um best edit [ __ ] hey man way to
respect the editors and [ __ ] Kevin is a
wonderful letter and I thought if I
didn't put it in there he'd [ __ ] you
know beat the [ __ ] out of me or
something I had to get out of there how
come he loved your [ __ ] enemies
my own movies look at me mom
look it began with me complimenting you
and then you attacked me for being an
editor
I told you I'm getting you back to
Jersey ways baby come on that's true
that felt very Jersey that's why I lived
in California for the last 20 [ __ ]
years
all right here we go kids best
editing editing of film okay here we go
best editing ladies and gentlemen uh
everything's fine a panic attack in D
Major
fetch
Guiltless
sometime else
and finally sugar
and the winner of uh best editing the
prize for best hitting goes to
everything's fine a panic attack in D
Major
I don't want nobody gets hurt
he edited you
[Applause]
each other
[Laughter]
wow this is incredible thank you so much
uh this is the last Festival on our
Festival run so it means the world to be
here home in New Jersey I'm from East
Brunswick so this is this is really
freaking cool
um yeah hey New Jersey uh I just want to
say thank you to Kevin thank you to
Ernie this is really great guys thank
you so much
[Applause]
fellow cutter uh okay kids uh now we get
to best cinematography man this is the
folks that shoot the thing make it look
like what it does the eyes of any
filmmaker is the DP and that sounds
exactly as sexy as I meant it uh the
nominees ladies and gentlemen are
everything's fine a panic attack in D
Major
fear of the Woods
the fourth
Karma bombs
and time warp
[Applause]
uh ladies and gentlemen the prize as
chosen uh the award as chosen by the
audience for best cinematography goes to
Karma bums
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's do it what's up everybody
um thank you uh Ernie thank you
everybody
um we all know how hard it is to make
something especially today when the
studios are just like
keeping us away but their voices aren't
the ones that are that important they
can be and they're doing the fight but
we have to keep going and I'm not I know
it's not that inspirational I'm not
trying to be but thank you thank you
very much and this is Brandon our main
actor say something uh thank you I love
all of you I don't know what to say I'm
nervous
and last thing I'll say is we made
lifelong friends lifelong friends here
and we're gonna all collaborate and
we're going to continue to thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
uh okay folks moving down
best original music
uh
uh the nominees are everything's fine a
panic attack in D Major
the Hat Man
the jogger
stalked
and finally suddenly
in my head these are all going on on the
screen behind me probably not right
thinking I was somewhere better
next year next year
next year we put all the pictures up
yeah you're one right [ __ ] give us
some room [ __ ] off
um next year for sure okay ladies and
gentlemen the uh winner of the award for
best original music is everything's fine
a panic attack a D major
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh you already served for me so this is
uh Dave Seaman the wizard Behind the
Music from this movie thank you Zach
thank you everybody thank you Kevin
thank you Ernie thank you all of you uh
also as a guy from New Brunswick New
Jersey it's so special to be here
so special to be your s mod castle and
um music is the language of our soul the
day that Zach and I had to teach the
music to the cast we met at a piano room
in Colombia about 30 minutes before the
cast was going to show up and we wrote
the songs uh so I'm so glad this worked
out
[Laughter]
okay folks
next up we're doing best Ensemble which
is just all the actors right there it is
all of the actors ladies and gentlemen
uh the nominees for best Ensemble are
darts
dead on the vine
maybe someday
the invention
and the [ __ ]
and the best Ensemble award goes to dead
on the vine
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
attention
excellent job
um I've been very lucky enough to be in
two of the films by this writer and
director Mark Brown and um uh his films
keep on winning best Ensemble and that
has got to be something about the teams
that he puts together so this is for you
mark
[Applause]
there we go watch out
okay kids
we're up to best documentary short
and to do this yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
hand off the mic why don't you go help
on all intro uh kids we're not sitting
here today
um if uh the first film I made didn't
work out for me and it worked out for me
it literally came down to one person uh
I didn't make the film to go to Sundance
to the film festival I thought our film
wasn't Sundance worthy all I knew about
Sundance was that Steven Soderberg
wanted for sex lives videotape that
movie was in color and Andy McDowell was
in it she'd been another movie so as far
as I was concerned Sundance was for
better films than mine we weren't aiming
for that we were aiming for the iffm the
independent feature film Marketplace not
even a festival it was an event that the
ifp uh the independent feature project
would throw every year at the Angelica
Film Center and I'd seen a news report
about it there was a thing called made
in New York that they put on like TV
years ago
and one section of it they talked about
this iffm this marketplace where people
would bring their films of young
filmmakers and hope to find distribution
for them and stuff like that then I'd
had an article that was in the Village
Voice that Amy talbin had written about
Richard linklater who made the film that
inspired me to become a filmmaker film
called slacker and in that piece she
talked about how Richard had gone to the
iffm the year before is a work in
progress and then he was there that year
with a finished film that Orion Classics
was releasing in theaters and stuff so
that document was a map to me a treasure
map it still exists in my office back
home in New Jersey framed in a cheap
plastic frame that I bought like back in
the early 90s because that was like the
moment in The Matrix where [ __ ] Neo
sees zeros and ones I read that article
and I was like oh my God it's this
simple all I have to do is make a movie
and go to the iffm and all my dreams
will come true
and it didn't quite work out that way
um ultimately it did but in the
beginning it didn't
um the Fest the marketplace is not a
festival you pay a certain amount of
money and you get a slot and stuff like
that and it's up to you to fill that
slot with as many potential Distributors
exhibitors press as possible you're
meant to do all the work they're just
giving you a venue in which to show it
and a time when a bunch of other people
who are in this world might be around
and be interested in watching and stuff
so the onus is on you so me and Scott
Mosher would go up to the city every day
and hang up like posters for the movie
handmade billets and stuff for clerks
which was screening on Sunday October
3rd at 11 A.M which I kept telling Scott
Moser and anybody who would listen of
course they put us at the end of the
marketplace where the best [ __ ] film
so clearly somebody knows that the
future is bright for us and they put us
in the sweetest [ __ ] spot man Sunday
morning at 11 A.M when everyone gets up
and wants to watch movies and [ __ ]
so we went every day of the marketplace
and it was packed we saw movies like
Lodge Kerrigan made a movie called clean
shaven that also went to Sundance later
on and stuff and it played at a bunch of
festivals the screening was [ __ ]
packed we went and saw a documentary a
mockumentary called the making of and
God spoke about the production of a
Biblical film uh very funny [ __ ] pack
so each time we went to a screening it
was packed and me and Moshi were like
God Sunday's going to be so packed and
so [ __ ] amazing it's going to be
unbelievable and [ __ ] we were prepared
we'd seen what it looked like and we
were like are our shots coming and then
Sunday morning came and we're outside
the Angelica and we took pictures you
could see him on that secret stash book
or anywhere online these black and white
pictures that exist from that [ __ ]
day October 3rd about 10 30 in the
morning before I go into the Angelica
and discover that nobody wakes up on a
Sunday morning to go see films and the
only people who were in the theater were
people who worked on the movie with me
so it was me Jeff Anderson Brian
o'holleran Scott Mosher David Klein
Marilyn gigliotti Lisa spoonauer Vincent
Pereira was there
um Eddie hapstack because he was taking
pictures
Kristen Mosher Scott's sister who I was
dating at the time and that was it we
walked into the theater and we were
alone in the [ __ ] theater it was just
like going to see a Kevin Smith movie
and nowadays you walk in and they're
like is this part of the joke
um so we were alone in the theater and
that was the crashing of my dreams that
was the first moment that it had ever
occurred to me that this wouldn't work
and I was like I've read that article I
knew everything I was supposed to do I
checked all the boxes I made it flick
I'm bringing here the iffm like what do
you mean I'm not going to have the same
experience as Richard linklater and for
the first 10 minutes of Clerks as it
played for the first time anywhere
publicly on a big screen in a legit
[ __ ] movie theater and stuff my only
16 millimeter print all I could think
throughout the first 10 minutes was just
like what the [ __ ] have I done like this
looks like it was shot through a glass
of milk and everybody is cursing their
[ __ ] heads off like why did I think I
was a filmmaker this is unbelievable I
saw I've gone to movies my whole life
never once did I think about making a
movie I saw Richard linkler did it I was
like maybe I could do that too I was
like Pride goeth before the fall I've
been hoisted on my own petard I had a
running monologue about what an idiot I
was that was the whole first 10 minutes
of Clerks as I watched it pretty much
just as a casting crew screening there
are some other bodies in the room and
they might have come in when the movie
was going on and [ __ ] but I wasn't
focused on them I was focused on the
bodies that weren't in the [ __ ] room
important lesson kids sidebar it's
always focus on the people who show up
don't matter who don't come who matters
is who comes and that was never truer
than on that day
so
at the end of that screening you know
about 10 minutes 15 minutes in the
screening the panic attack had subsided
and I uh cognitively reframed the whole
experience I was like look you spent
twenty seven thousand of 575 bucks
making this movie that is cheaper than
one year of Tisch film school which at
that point was forty thousand dollars a
year so it's like for one year of Tish
you got to make a whole last movie
that's yours so like don't you know
don't sell out on this you you yes it
costs a lot of money and you're gonna be
paying this movie off on your credit
cards probably for the better part of
the rest of your life this means you're
gonna have to get a second job in
addition to Quick Stop but do that and
like this is honestly I swear to Christ
the monologue that went through my head
about 10 15 minutes into the first
public exhibition of Clerks I said make
sure you do that pay off your bills and
then do this one more time before you
die Because You Loved who you were when
this was happening for the first time in
your life you felt like you were in the
right exact place and who you are
supposed to [ __ ] be so don't let the
lack of success make you sell out on
this and run and be like yeah I knew it
was a dumb idea what the [ __ ] was I
thinking don't pull your movie out once
a year to watch it to be like there's
the guy who [ __ ] ruined everything
for us and [ __ ] like that don't sell out
on it do it again because you think it
feels right so by the middle of the
screening I was able to kick back and
relax and realize that I was watching
the movie that I made with my friends in
a movie theater where I was inspired to
make a movie only two and two years and
change prior that's when I saw Richard
link later slacker was on my birthday
August 2nd 1991 my 21st birthday and
there we were watching clerks you know
in an empty theater but on October 3rd
1993 so two years two months like to
aggregate to a [ __ ] dream come true
and for the beginning of that dream come
true all I could focus on was like oh it
wasn't the exact [ __ ] dream I had and
[ __ ] wasn't until I got comfortable with
it I was like look at what you did like
you of all [ __ ] people you're here in
this movie theater watching your [ __ ]
movie man like enjoy it man enjoy it so
I did I kicked back and I enjoyed that
[ __ ] now
at the end of the movie
um there were four people in attendance
who were not part of my party
um I often talk about two I'm gonna tell
you about one during the Jay and Silent
Bob reboot Road Show tour some guy gave
me an envelope and on the front he said
I was at the very first screening of
clerks at the Angelica me and my then
girlfriend were not together anymore we
sat he told me exactly where sat and I
knew exactly who the [ __ ] it was and
[ __ ] and so he came backstage and I
talked to him I was like why did you
[ __ ] go and this is years later
literally like 27 years later I was like
why did you [ __ ] go and he was just
like we had anything to do it was cold
that morning
so we went into the theater because it
was warm and [ __ ] and he's like and we
thought the movie was cool and I
remember saying to my girlfriend he
might go places someday and he goes you
[ __ ] went places and [ __ ] and I was
like I did thank you so
they were there they came in at a
certain point during the movie theater
during the screening just to get a warm
theater and they stayed for the show
that was pretty nice I didn't speak to
them after the screening I spoke to a
woman who came up to me and she said
she's looked very dire and she goes do
you know people like the people you put
in this movie and I was one of the
people that I put in the movie and I was
surrounded by people who I'd put in the
movie who were those people and [ __ ] and
I was like a little bit and she goes uh
[ __ ] hate New Jersey
and I was like oh that's where we made
the movie and she goes I know
and she goes I got a theory that all the
Nazis who ever died are reincarnated and
that's what populates New Jersey
that was the first review of Clerks I
ever got
and after she said that I wasn't clever
enough to come up with a witty retort I
was like oh that was all I said and then
during the pause after that she goes I
guess I'll give you my head shot and she
gave me her headshot she was an actress
and that actress is Jennifer Lopez no I
was kidding uh
I don't know who that [ __ ] actress
was but that's who I spoke to after the
first screening of my movie now Scott
Mosher on the other hand spoke to
somebody else Scott Moser spoke to a guy
who had come in and and he was sitting
at the front I remember his bald head at
the front of the theater it was like
Mystery Science Theater before it was
[ __ ] Mystery Science Theater and he
was watching the movie and he laughed
periodically I heard that dude gafon and
[ __ ] made me feel kind of good in this
moment of misery where I was like
nobody's [ __ ] here well that guy's
[ __ ] laughing but he didn't have a
badge that indicated Miramax fine line
or importance or anything like that his
badge said his name and it said ICI
which meant nothing to me and [ __ ] so I
didn't pursue that guy I didn't pursue
the Nazi lady either she [ __ ] pursued
me
Scott you know was there and the guy
with the ICI badge came up to him and
and started saying nice things to him I
wasn't there for the conversation but
this is what Scott reported he said I
talked to a guy because I told Scott I
was like I met the Nazi lady and he goes
well I met somebody better I said who he
goes a guy who said we should submit to
Sundance and I was like was he from
Sundance and he goes no it's from a
company ICI or something I was like what
what why would we submit to Sunday it
says color movies and movie stars he
says it's not always that he says like
we are a Sundance movie he's like this
is what the U.S Film Festival
which Robert Redford came in and turned
into the Sundance Film Festival was
predicated on it was like finding the
outsider voices not necessarily the
people who are competent at what they do
but just people who could tell a [ __ ]
story that captured a piece of Americana
and so he was telling Scott that this
movie does that you should submit to
Sundance and so that was it walked away
and I'll be honest with you we didn't
think about submitting descendants not
like we after that said yeah that's the
next step I was done I had only planned
up to the iffm my dream had only gone
that [ __ ] far I never went beyond
that because I thought everything would
happen there and [ __ ] so I was Ill
prepared for what happened next and I
had 12 hours to wallow in [ __ ] misery
and think about what I'd done and how it
was so [ __ ] stupid and [ __ ] and then
in the morning I got a phone call and it
was a woman going um hi I'm looking for
Kevin Smith I said I was Kevin Smith she
goes I'm Amy talbin I write for the
Village Voice and I was like
okay who is this really and she goes
Jamie Tab and I was like [ __ ] this
is Brian Johnson put you up to this
didn't he like who would [ __ ] know
that like Amy talbin like has an article
on my [ __ ] wall and she goes what I
was like yeah I [ __ ] the the reels
and Deals article about Richard
linklater is framed and hanging on my
wall written by Amy Tobin she goes well
this is going to be the best interview I
ever [ __ ] gave
I said are you really Amy Thomas she
goes yeah she's going nobody's ever
accused me of not being who the [ __ ] I
am
so weird I was like how'd you get this
number she was like I called the number
that was in the iffm program guide and A
man answered he said he was your father
because I had listed my parents home
phone number and stuff and so I was like
that was my father and he was like she
goes I know because only a parent would
be as surprised as he was
that someone was interested in your
movie
I was like really she goes yeah he was
just like someone wants to see my son's
movie that's weird and he goes yeah
here's a number you could reach him at
and she's like and so I'm calling you
and I was like oh my God yeah I mean why
are you calling she goes I heard that
your movie was the Undiscovered Gem of
the marketplace and so I was like who
said that she's like I'm not a liberty
to say but I trust his opinion very much
so will you send me a copy of this
clerks I'd like to include it in my
reels and Deals article this year the
same article that I had cut out I was
going to be in one year later or two
years later I was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
it'll never get better than this then
the phone rang 10 minutes later and it
was a guy who's going hi I'm Larry
Kardash I work for uh run new directors
new films it's a sister program to the
New York Film Festival you can only ever
do it once as a filmmaker with your
first film and so I didn't even know
about this thing he called out of the
blue and he was like uh we we're
interested in your movie Clerks I said
why how did you hear about it he goes I
heard it was the Undiscovered Gem of the
marketplace and I was like from who and
he's like I'm not a liberty to say
he's gone but the person who told me
about it I trust a great deal so would
you send me a copy we would like to see
if we'd like to include it and I sent
him a copy and new director's new films
was I think the second Film Festival I
ever played at over in the Museum of
Modern Art man it was [ __ ] massive
um third person that called was uh Peter
Broderick Peter Broderick wrote a series
of articles for filmmaker magazine in
those days where he would talk to
filmmakers and they would break down
their process and their most most
importantly their budgets in those days
it wasn't like now where if you want to
know something you go to the Internet
look it up you'll probably find that
information filmmakers kept their
budgets very close to the vest because
they didn't want [ __ ] Distributors
potential Distributors know how much
they spent so they can jack up the
purchase price hopefully get as much as
possible so that information was vaulted
which means you didn't know what things
cost if you didn't do it yourself and
we'd never done it so we didn't know
what anything cost but Peter brought her
quote this article that had the laws of
gravity
um
which was Nick Gomez's movie
um The Living End which was gregoraki's
movie and a movie called together alone
I forget the name of the filmmaker but
it was a seven thousand dollar movie set
in an apartment with two guys very close
to like what clerks was essentially so
each one of these movies broke their
budgets down and what things cost this
is how much the film costs like the
actual film the process unraw film that
they used to shoot the movie this is
what a Niagara a recording device to
record all the sound costs this is what
renting of a steam because this was
golden information for people that
didn't have access to that information
and stuff and so Peter Broderick called
me the third person that morning and he
was just like hi I've heard that clerks
is the I said the Undiscovered Gem of
the marketplace I was like what are you
really Peter Broderick I was like
because we used your article to figure
out what clerk was clerks was going to
cost we figured like based on the three
that if we hit 25
000 we would start worrying anything
over that was worry time and [ __ ] he's
like what's your movie call I was like
27 575 I've been worried for so long and
[ __ ] and he goes well I would like to
profile your film in a similar article
to the one you're talking about and I
was like I'll do that in a heartbeat but
you got to tell me right now I was like
who [ __ ] told you about the movie
like nobody was there except a chick who
said I was a Nazi like is it was she the
golden path like what
and he goes there is a man at your
screening named Bob Hawk and Bob Hawk
saw your movie and he's been telling
literally everybody about your film and
I was like why and he's like [ __ ]
loved it I guess he's gone so please
don't pass on the information I know he
wants to keep it discreet and stuff he
doesn't want to get hounded by their
filmmakers but he was the one
responsible I said can you get me this
guy's number he's like I can see if he
wants to give his number to you and I'll
put you in contact
and so it took about a week and finally
I was put in contact uh with the person
who had literally changed my life Bob
Hawk I called him Mr Hawk for the first
two years of our friendship because
he was you needed that honorific when
somebody changes your life irrevocably
you can't just call him Bob
so he was Mr Hawk like forever we met
Bob and Bob talked about why he went to
see clerks I was like why did you go to
this movie I was always fascinated still
to this day I was fascinated by what
makes a person choose my [ __ ] over
somebody else's [ __ ] and considering
that nobody else was there like Bob got
up early on a cold [ __ ] Sunday
morning in October and went to that
movie so I was like what brought you to
that theater what made you see that
movie that made you talk to all these
people and [ __ ] like that and like
literally suddenly I went from like
wanting to never wake up again to like
[ __ ] like I can't wait to wake up
tomorrow to find out what happens
[ __ ] next like what made you go to
the theater and Bob was like the photo
in the catalog that you listed was so
sad and terrible
it instantly made me feel sorry for you
and he goes and I had to see what kind
of film put that photo in the catalog
so
he's like I got up early and I came and
I'm so glad I did your film like spoke
to me I'm from New Jersey I'm originally
from the state
um I think it's an important film and I
think you should submit to the Sundance
Film Festival I'm I'm an advisor I tell
them the movies I like and they take
them into consideration I'm going to
sing the Praises of this movie
so we did submit to Sundance and Bob did
sing the praises to the movie and uh
we're in Atlantic Highlands so we're not
very far from where this happened three
miles away from the moment my life
changes forever and I'm working a quick
stop I'm behind the counter and Bob Hawk
calls me and he goes Kevin I just want
you to know they have narrowed down the
450 submissions this year to 20 films
and your films your film is one of the
20. now you know they only take 14. he's
going but right now you're so close and
I don't know what's going to happen he's
going to talk to these people all the
time I know that some people really love
your movie and I know that some people
hate it and don't think it should be a
part of the festival it's not indicative
of American Film they think it's
amateurish and sloppy but then there are
other people that think that this is
exactly what Sundance is all about he's
going but I can't guarantee which way
it's going to go but I just thought you
should know that like this little movie
that you didn't think was good enough to
go to Sundance is now in consideration
and made it to the top [ __ ] 20. and I
was like it can't get better than that
and he goes it can but it might not
so I was like thank you Bob thanks for
calling man and I hung up and I was
feeling like you know you got to
remember when we showed the iffm all of
my hope [ __ ] died that day and it was
slowly being rekindled and reborn with
all these phone calls and all this
traction and suddenly hearing that like
the movie got close at Sundance was
enough you know it's like I don't have
to be the best I just want to get
[ __ ] close especially considering
we'd never [ __ ] done it before
hung up the phone I went back to work
ringing up [ __ ] people and stuff and
then 20 minutes later the phone rang
and it's the same pay phone that Dante
uses in clerks if you've ever seen that
movie and uh I go over the phone I pick
it up and uh he goes Kevin
and it's Bob and I go Bob
and he goes you're in Sundance Film
Festival my life [ __ ] changed
instantly
one person can absolutely make a [ __ ]
difference uh and this person made such
a difference in my life uh he's never
left my life shortly after that he wound
up moving in with me and we lived
together for two years in Red Bank over
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash he was
there when I put together Mall Rats he
came with me and Scott to the Black
Tower at Universal pitch Mall Rats we
were all hanging out with Bob for his
birthday in Los Angeles we took him and
he'd never been to Disneyland we went to
Disneyland and then my then agent was
like Universal wants you to come in and
Pitch right now and I was like we're in
[ __ ] Disneyland we got Bob it's his
birthday like bring Bob
so we went back to the Black Tower and
[ __ ] pitched at Universal and the
whole time they were like who's the old
man
and at first we were like that's our
grandpa
but we were like that's Bob without Bob
nobody sees clerks and you guys even
have this conversation with us and Bob
was like I've never seen a pitch go on
you know and
and we pitched he was there for that
when I was building Chasing Amy after
everything fell apart man a lot of
people like Mall Rats now but when it
came out it [ __ ] died my career died
with it were not for Chasing Amy had
resurrected my career made people think
that I was a good filmmaker or something
like that and the person who was there
when I was writing it every step of the
way the guy who was fed pages every
[ __ ] night including the pages where
I came to like a certain point in the
script where Bob's like what happens
next and I was like Bob
this is going to be a little out there
but I think I'm going to have Holden
suggest they all have a [ __ ]
threesome and Bob who's a wonderful man
and also gay is the day is long was like
[ __ ] do that
he goes oh my God that would be so brave
Kevin do that and I did and it changed
my [ __ ] life again man like people
considered me a brave filmmaker because
I had this geriatric man going do it do
it do it like the devil
um this person is one of my favorite
people in the entire [ __ ] world and
when we were building the festival I
told Ernie we got to reach out to Bob
he's got to be involved in some way so
here to present the documentary
categories is The Man Without whom none
of us would be here tonight Robert Hawk
ladies and gentlemen
foreign
okay
[Music]
that was a [ __ ] long introduction
[Applause]
and I'm only going to say [ __ ] twice and
I've already said it twice okay
[Laughter]
I
did I want to keep this short
um
and I do keep it pretty short
in comparison anyway
one thing about why I went to see clerks
at 11 A.M on a Sunday morning
I was
yeah
the still was shitty
and that's my last [ __ ] okay
but
the synopsis intrigued me
because it was about a convenience store
and I'd never seen a film in a
convenience store and I thought it was a
great
setting to make a comment
about
life
in America
and
I don't know I just I said this could be
an awful movie a really terrible
amateurish
movie I don't know but I'm a Jersey Boy
and this is a jersey film
and I will give it 15 to 20 minutes and
it and at this point
in the market
I don't sit through a whole film unless
it grabs me
and so you sit in your seat in a certain
way
which is not
leaning back and relaxing you have your
hand on your bag and you're ready to go
but you want to give it a Time
and by 15 20 minutes at most
I
I relaxed I sat back I took my hand off
my bag and I said I'm in for the ride
and I do feel it was a very and is
continued to be a very important film so
mwah
anyway oh so I had that okay so I don't
yeah right okay so anyway
I uh I was
really very happy in my retirement I am
retired
but I was very happy when Ernie and
Kevin asked me
to watch
the documentaries and I
and I was very impressed
with the
with the quality of the submissions
and uh
it was very hard
for me to choose all the competition now
you the audience chose
who won but I want everyone who made a
documentary to know I was really
impressed for the first year of any
Festival even if it is Kevin and he is
global
but I was really impressed so anyway
the first award is to best documentary
short and the nominees are apartment 38.
Bendix sight unseen
how America killed my mother
would vibrations
[Applause]
and Valerie
and the winner is apartment 38.
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
um I
it's movie cow
um I this documentary I worked on um
apartment 38 and I won't keep you long
but it's about my great uncle Alfonso
who recently passed away about two years
ago and
um it's about a first-born American
Generation
Um here from Italy and um if he was here
today he'd be so proud that not about
this whole crowd being able to see his
story being able to hear his song New
Jersey his theme song so I know if he
was here today he'd be very very um
he would be very proud and I just want
to thank each and every one of you for
attending the festival
Ernie Kevin thank you so much for
hosting this and to all of you for
entering films congratulations
thank you very much
[Applause]
so sorry everybody I told my partner I
would give Kevin Smith one of these it's
an official apartment 38 t-shirt
[Applause]
oh
hey baby
okay
best documentary feature
at the drive-in
book of hearth
history of metal and horror
[Applause]
journey to Royal a World War II Rescue
Mission
and
A Million Miles Away
and the winner is
book of hearth
[Applause]
I will accept the oh
your hair good
right
holy [ __ ]
uh this has been six years in the making
for me the the film is about a an artist
who collected celebrity signatures in a
Bible for 20 years so talk about
devotion and I think that's what we all
have here as filmmakers and uh at the
end of the day it's it's about
friendship because me following him
around for a year we became good buddies
and that's what we really need we gotta
stick together and I have my good friend
Sammy here he did the music for it
and just like how he was the subject ran
up to celebrities bothering them I ran
up to Kevin one day in February of 2020
right before the pandemic and I
interviewed him
and for the film and he's in it and he
gave me the warmest [ __ ] hug I've
ever received from a man
and I want to recreate that right now
give me a [ __ ] hug
thank you everybody Tammy
holy moly thank you so much really means
a lot and uh I've I've come to a lot of
these uh Awards ceremonies and
I haven't enjoyed them but this
this man is such a wonderful Storyteller
I've been captivated all night so thanks
and this has been great thank you
everyone
[Applause]
okay we are at
putting that aside um okay folks we're
at the best
actor comedy feature category
and the nominees are
Rebecca DeMarco marijuana minutes
Richard Holman songs of the sloth
Alex Molina afternooner
Dylan Riley Snyder for crabs
and Jeremy riesh am I right rich thank
you [ __ ] why is the E there never
mind we'll talk later uh Jeremy risch
for the marshmallow Mystery Tour
and the winner of the award for best
actor uh in a comedy feature is Rebecca
DeMarco marijuana minutes
foreign
[Applause]
I wrote a speech and I'm going to take
as long as I damn well please
um yeah get out of here uh smart Castle
has been amazing
um everyone that I've met has been so
kind and generous and thank you it means
the world I'm not going to cry yet
there's a lot to get through
um and I can't wait for next year
because you guys really nailed it and
I'm not just saying that because I won
but really this has been an amazing
amazing experience
um Ryan thank you for giving me space on
set to be a little weirdo
um I've never met a more collaborative
director and it really the movie was
better for it and I'm really really
appreciative Justin Nick Mike Monica
you've stroked my ego on and offset
since day one
um and it means a lot to me obviously as
an actor my ego's big already and it
helps
um Jared you're one of my closest
friends thank you for driving me to set
most days I'll pay you back at some
point eventually we'll talk later
um Sophia I love you you're the best
scene partner that I have ever worked
with you're an amazing actress and a
more amazing human don't move to LA for
selfish reasons
um
I did have the chance to scope out my
competition I got to watch afternooner
and the marshmallow Mystery Tour today
they were both hilarious and amazing
films and I'm even more humbled
accepting this award for seeing them I
didn't get to see the other movies in in
my category but I did stalk you on IMDb
so if you want to be friends I promise
I'm nice just come up later
um I was the only woman nominated in my
category so I want to accept this award
on behalf of all women who think they're
funny
thank you never stop ripping on the bit
and don't take no [ __ ] from the boys
thank you thank you
uh okay I feel like I got yelled at
um
here we go folks uh best actor in a
feature uh drama feature here we go
um Serena Brown dead on the vine
did I get the name right thank you
Elizabeth Hursh Talbert 12 months
Jenny Raven Woodland Gray
Tom Sawyer dead on the vine
and Allison Thornton Guiltless
foreign
and the winner of the best actor in
drama feature category the award goes to
Tom Sawyer dead on the vine
[Applause]
thank you so much
wow thank you
so
best actor
so any one of you inspiring or aspiring
actors give up now because best
so
thank you
speak
ing
all right folks best screenplay man here
we go writing this is my [ __ ]
favorite subject in the world
um look directing is cool we all know
that and she is the sexy uh acting is a
mystery and and and really the kind of
meat of of the job but screenplay anyone
who writes you know you it's the closest
you get to Playing God unless you're a
woman you actually give birth that's way
closer but for [ __ ] you know creating
something out of nothing whole cloths
[ __ ] nothing like it and you know
they say it every [ __ ] Ward ceremony
like it all begins with the script
um it's true it's the reason they say
that because there ain't nothing without
the power of the words in here some
powerful words are written by the
following folks best screenplay uh Award
nominees folks are James cleave sometime
else
thank you
Patrick Clement must love pie
Sam Gill for fetch
Ari grabbed for a king's betrayal
and Sasha pasternack for dream of me
and the award for best screenplay goes
to Patrick Clement must love pie
foreign
let's give it to somebody else the next
winner no
uh we accept this oh sorry we accept
this on behalf of uh of uh Patrick we
should take a picture though right
be Patrick
you're gonna make it my dick weren't you
I saw it you were going for it Jimmy's
influenced me a little bit I feel like I
feel that way uh okay kids uh we're
going to Best Director uh look let's be
honest uh director is the best [ __ ]
people on the planet
I have no bias when I say that it just
comes from my own personal experience uh
the director is the dreamer the chief
dreamer ladies and gentlemen not the
only dreamer on a set and certainly not
the only [ __ ] Storyteller I remember
one time I was on red State and I was
walking by and I like a certain point in
my career I stopped directing and
started hosting the movies instead
treating it like a party because that's
what we're there to do have fun and [ __ ]
so I'll go around talk to everybody how
you doing it just talking to Scotty
props I was walking by I was like how
you doing Scotty props and he's like I'm
doing good I was like I'm just making my
film he goes I'm making my film to him
just a filmmaker making my filming your
film and it stopped me and I was like
what are you talking about and he goes
well you're making your film but I'm
making my film in your film and I was
like you're [ __ ] right man like
that's [ __ ] awesome and [ __ ] I was
like don't ever tell anyone that because
everyone thinks the director is in
charge but really it's everyone makes
their own film within the film and the
director's job is to make sure it all
coalesces and comes together the
director gets all the credit even though
they don't always deserve it but the
director gets every [ __ ] bullet man
if the movie don't work even in the
slightest they don't go like well the
acting well the screenwriter they go
right for the [ __ ] jugular like this
[ __ ] director and [ __ ] I know that
because it happens to me all the time
um
so uh for my fellow directors out there
I uh salute you uh not only for the
glory you'll receive but for the bullets
you take over the course of your career
as we all know it's worth it there are
two things I say to myself after
everything I do generally I have to say
it after things that don't work out it's
not necessarily sentiments you say when
things succeed it's definitely helpful
sentiment When Things Fall Apart or
don't work as you wish number one was
um you know no matter what it is like
something like let's say yoga hosers
happens right and I'm like [ __ ] why did
I do that and [ __ ] first thing I say is
you wanted this oh my god did you want
this you changed the [ __ ] shape and
fabric of the universe to make this
happen you made people come all the way
from other you made Johnny Depp put on
makeup for this [ __ ] thing like you
wanted this so [ __ ] enjoy it doesn't
matter it didn't work out the way you
hoped and [ __ ] this is what you wanted
[ __ ] enjoy it and the second thing I
say is a little easier on myself and it
goes something like this what was the
alternative seriously what were you
gonna do you knew you could do this
thing you knew it was [ __ ] humanly
possible you knew you could make it you
knew you could stick the landing and you
chose not to why because you were scared
[ __ ] you like [ __ ] what was the
alternative there was no alternative
these directors know that there was no
alternative and they're here tonight and
we're celebrating them congratulations
my fellow director nominees
okay
nominees for Best Director award number
one we go to Clinton Cornwell 12 months
Sam Gill for fetch
Keon hediati for karma bums
do I get the name right
yes [ __ ] hey man two for two uh this
is where I lose it Leo mcguigan
he's not here for the invention
and Sasha pasternack for dream of me
and the winner the first time we ever
gave a best or Director award uh here at
the smog first annual smog Castle Film
Festival is kind of historic for us man
for the rest of our lives that we do
this there'll always be a first name at
the top of the list and that name for
best director this year goes to Kian
hediati man for karma bucks
laughs
wow
that's quite amazing thank you everybody
[Applause]
um
this movie that we made is we tried to
make something that um is about America
and what's kind of going on in the whole
world
and uh like I'm sure everybody else that
has been involved in films here
we all got screwed in one way or another
on set
um we got shot at
uh we got harassed by KKK
um knives pulled on us bit by tarantulas
blah blah blah and a lot of people said
that we couldn't do it and a lot of
people have said that you guys can't do
it and we're all [ __ ] doing it so
thank you thank you guys very much and
last thing I forgot to say thank you to
my cinematographer who won the last
award uh Manny Andrade I love you
everybody on the team I love you thank
you
thank you
okay
next up folks how many words we got left
four [ __ ] this is almost over uh how are
you guys enjoying it so far
[Applause]
I'm with the other guy award ceremonies
can be painful but this has been
actually pretty fun but I I'm a big
Kevin Smith fan so I've been
uh here we go folks uh the horror best
horror the award uh for best horror the
nominees are
children of sin
Gravedigger
she picked me
they see you
and Woodland Gray
the winner of the award for best horror
goes to gravedigger
foreign
thank you
uh I'm much better at putting uh words
to paper than saying this out loud but
here we go uh years ago Kevin visited
Atlanta and he told us in a q a that it
costs nothing to encourage an artist and
I could not agree with that more thank
you for always doing so thank you to
everyone who pays that forward and
biggest thank you
uh to my wife who pushed me one step
further every uh step of the way for
this path of making this film when I
said I have an idea she's like you
should write that and I was like okay I
have a script she's like you need to
film that and every single time I
faltered you were there to make sure I
took the very next step to get this film
done so thank you thank you all thank
you Kevin
Ernie thank you so much for watching our
film
as a professional stunt performers we
sometimes get recognized for work on
camera but to finally be recognized for
a work behind camera is such an honor we
hit our heads for a living how did we
write and direct and produce something
is beyond me and it's really thanks to
our amazing cast and crew uh thank you
guys so much I literally submitted to
this Festival day one so thank you so so
much and uh Gravedigger is 30 pages of a
full feature film script and this has
inspired me to go way beyond that thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so very much and I just want
to give it up to these two it's been
such a pleasure and the vision of Lloyd
Pitts and Julia Maggio and thank you so
much this has been an amazing experience
thank you
okay folks now we're into uh best
animation
um [ __ ] I love cartoons uh you're not
allowed to call them cartoons but when
it's something official like this but
they are cartoons uh if I could draw I
wouldn't make all these terrible movies
that people hate so much so I admire
anybody who can pull off animation uh
the nominees for best the award for best
animation are fetch
the forbidden zone
lady Betty
message from the future
and suddenly
and the winner of the award for best
animation goes to the forbidden zone
no
the trifecta
um I don't know about you all but me and
Ernie are the big winners tonight man
[ __ ]
three Awards and three Awards and
Counting man we could go home with two
more [ __ ]
uh all right folks we're down to the
final two
um best comedy feature
these are the nominees
the marshmallow Mystery Tour
marijuana minutes
afternooner
turbo Cola
and finally darts
and the winner for uh best comedy
feature the award for best comedy
feature uh the first annual smodcast
Castle Film Festival goes to the
marshmallow Mystery Tour
yeah
Bernie was trying to take your award
to hear you here now we're like
marijuana
thank you so much
um well this uh this has been years in
in the making more years than I will
admit to you all it's embarrassing but
uh I'm so happy to be here my brother
who we did this together with uh can't
be here he knows he shot you Kevin Smith
at a uh outside the New York Public
Library many years ago he's a
hard-working DP and he was featuring you
so many years ago you know he's one of
those guys out there with a camera and
the two of us wrote and directed this
and we want to thank everybody that
believed in it this the lead actor
Jeremy risch our parents my wife suhair
my kids who are in it every Iraqi
Refugee who he also featured in it and
one last thing I'll tell you all is did
you know that when Roald Dahl wrote
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
that the Oompa Loompas were originally
pygmy pygmy slaves in Africa did you
guys know that well that's kind of the
origin of this film was wondering well
what if we did the real Willy Wonka
would you still laugh and uh I think you
still can but you have to think and we
got a letter from Gene Wilder supporting
it when we did it and uh it's the
greatest thing ever to be here and thank
you to this man for making it real
thanks that's it
golden calf
thank you
one award left ladies and gentlemen will
Ernie and I win it let's find out
uh finally we end uh with best uh drama
feature ladies and gentlemen here we go
the nominees uh for the award for best
drama in the future category
12 months
dead on the vine
Guiltless
Karma bombs
and maybe someday
and the winner of the award for best
drama the first annual smog Castle Film
Festival feature category is
dead on the vine ladies and gentlemen
come on up get your award
s
now
thank you
I didn't want the accident
[Applause]
you're swapping oh um this is awesome
um
this film shouldn't really have existed
you know we we made it out of
out of spite to covid I guess we uh so
many of our projects fell apart just as
covert kicked off and we were all going
crazy doing nothing
and so this film is I guess is dedicated
to everyone that um
had nothing to do and said yes when we
asked them
um if they'd come to a Vineyard in the
middle of nowhere
um just after lockdown and make a fun
film with us and uh
most of them are here as you can see so
thank you very much this is alola the
amazing producer
[Applause]
wow what an amazing experience this has
been thank you so much
um this couldn't have happened without
all of the support
um we had from Friends uh random people
I pulled into the project to uh come and
live on a Vineyard I mean he wouldn't
live on a Vineyard right for two weeks
that was the main selling point of come
to work on our film but it's been an
incredible experience and working with
Mark this director has been amazing so
on to the next one yeah
thank you New Jersey
hey
okay
upstairs
um that's it no more Awards to give out
uh kids uh since everything is a [ __ ]
anecdote to me I'll tell you a quick
story and then we'll get out of here
it's about 30 minutes long no um
uh when I was at the Sundance Film
Festival years ago with my first film
um we luckily got in but I had zero
expectation uh we would ever win
anything because you know it was very
amateurish film and [ __ ] like that we
wound up winning the filmmaker trophy
that year and it was so shocking and so
unexpected that when uh Scott Moser and
I got called up and I stumbled up to the
[ __ ] Podium and stuff I wasn't nearly
as eloquent as anybody tonight everybody
spoke so [ __ ] well and eloquently and
stuff and expressed themselves so
perfectly
um all I could say and you could find
footage of this I said knowing how much
I [ __ ] talk you would imagine oh my
God this [ __ ] blowhard all I
did was get up hold up their piece of
their Ward which was a glass and I was
like this is a really nice piece of
glass thank you
they stopped giving me Awards after that
I don't know if the two are combined
tonight it was wonderful to listen to
everybody get up uh and speak as they
did thank you for treating the film
festival as seriously as Ernie has
treated as seriously as we've all
treated we will definitely be doing this
again next year and do it for as long as
we've got walls around us
um
and Ernie would like to say something
about all the awards that he won tonight
well I want to know whose house they're
going to [ __ ]
my apartment's very near I know exactly
oh
[Applause]
[ __ ] that's a good one right there uh
again
stop playing with my [ __ ] man what the
[ __ ] man anyway uh thank you but uh as
some of you may know or may not know uh
we are having a small mixer at the wine
bar down the street above the harbor
side which is literally a one minute
walk
so when you go out of the theater
take a right
head down to the wine bar and join us so
there may have been some confusion to
some people but I will clarify so if you
were nominated obviously there's two of
you that were nominated and we put all
those all that information out so you're
on our list uh to come to the wine bar
then we put additional tickets on sale
that sold out really [ __ ] quick uh so
that's 70 additional tickets are also on
our list so if you're on that list you
know who you are you are all welcome to
come to the wine bar after we would love
to have everybody in the whole [ __ ]
town be there but we have a small venue
but next year the way things have been
going it looks like we're going to get
into a lot bigger house to have a bigger
party so I appreciate all of you for
coming out and thank you very much for
coming to the small Castle Film Festival
thank you
and kids that's a wrap man uh this was
uh something that at one point in my
life I was like oh my God I'm in the
middle of [ __ ] convenience tour how
are we supposed to pull this off and
Ernie's like I got you I got you and he
did get me man and uh my God it turned
into a wonderful event thank you all for
uh treating it seriously uh and thank
you all for making your art and thank
you all for making the choice to make a
[ __ ] thing
um if you do that I swear to you
um you're part of my heart forever uh
make things ladies and gentlemen make
things make a thing make another thing
make another [ __ ] thing make 10 more
things and then we die it's that simple
thank you all for being here have a
great night bye-bye
oh wow
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]